it's good to see all of you in my very
first SF data science meet up Jared
invited me here today to talk to you
about critical thinking in taming your
biases this is something that I taught
for a number of years inside Facebook
where I worked as a software engineer I
worked in facebook for a number of years
on our internal data tools I was really
interested in how people are using my
tools to actually do the process of
analysis what were they what decisions
were there making based on my tools and
I quickly noticed that the most
unreliable part of that process was the
part that was in front of the keyboard
and you might have noticed this yourself
just observing yourself that our brains
well like miraculously creative are also
very unreliable so I became very
interested in this topic I did some
reading on my own I was very influenced
by books such as Thinking Fast and Slow
by Daniel Kahneman some of you might
have read that book who's read that book
Daniel Daniel Kahneman came out maybe
three or four years ago as a New York
Times bestseller a really good book in
fact I stole a bunch of examples for
this presentation from that book so if
you recognize any of them please keep
the answers to yourself until your
neighbor gets a chance to look foolish
on themselves so that being said let's
talk about biases okay first some Theory
there's many ways of looking at this but
a very simple powerful way of looking at
biases is that they all stem from two
basic ways we have of thinking Daniel
Kahneman calls them system 1 and system
to system one is fast subconscious
automatic frequent emotional stereotypic
and intuitive it's always on and it's
effortless and stiffen a system to in
contrast is
lo it's conscious it's effortful it
happens only when we ask it to its
logical calculating and what we
traditionally call rational ok so the
this bias is stemmed from the conflict
in these two two fundamental ways of
thinking so when I'm going to present
the following examples to you try to
notice in your own mind whether it's
system one or system to talking let's do
a little demonstration to start off so
notice in your brain what happens when
you try to solve the following problem a
baton of all costs one dollar ten cents
the ball the bat costs one dollar more
than the ball how much does the ball
cost anybody anybody want to venture an
answer okay yeah first hand up was man
in black that is correct yes okay how
did you know the answer so you did the
algebra in your head really fast that's
excellent you would probably storm a
student did anybody have the answer of
ten cents pop into their head yes good a
few people are not a too embarrassed to
raise their hands i'm sure ab least
double as many had that number pop in
their head where does that come from
system one right it looks easy because
there's a dollar there's a there's a
tent there's a dollar and there's a ten
cents there's a bat and there's a ball
our system one just pops up an answer
right away and it takes system to to say
no wait a second that can't be right
because the algebra doesn't work out and
then you have to think it through step
by step the point is not that people
can't solve these problems but that
there are that our minds produce
predictably wrong answers in fact when
and this is even true of really smart
people when students of Princeton MIT
and Harvard were asked this question in
psychology experiments fifty percent of
them failed to answer correctly alright
so now let's get closer to home suppose
that you're in a company with me and we
make we make air B&B for dogs we call it
dog B&B so this is where you want when
you need a home for your dog when you're
on vacation we've just launched this
project we're really enthusiastic about
how it's going to do in the market okay
we analyzed the first bit of data and we
find that the top states per capita
attend to be sparsely populated rural
states in the Midwest the vote
Republican the top usage happens in
these states how would you explain this
any any ideas just you can blurt them
out there are more dogs in those states
okay possible definitely and in the back
there could be more dogs per capita yet
yes in the front there are fewer other
options yet it could be that they're
this underserved market all right
these are all really possible answers
that you might want to look into but
there's another explanation which is
purely statistical that is that the
smallest states in the United States
tend to be sparsely populated rural
states in the Midwest that vote
Republican elections and if you're
looking only at the top of the
distribution you are going to see the
smallest samples out there so by random
statistical chance the smallest states
are going to be at the top of the
distribution does that make sense like
imagine a bell curve you have big states
in small states the big States will be
clustered in the middle the small states
will be at either extreme so that so by
that logic even if there's no
fundamental difference you would expect
to see the Republicans sparsely
populated way states in the top dentist
region and in the bottom of the
distribution okay it takes some effort
to think this way when we read as a
result like this or not mines naturally
start to think about everything else we
know about those states about like
living on farms and things like that and
that could have something to do with it
but it's really helpful to also think
about just the underlying statistics of
what we're trying to measure I'm good
okay this phenomenon this bias of
generalizing from from any number is
called the law of small numbers it's a
joke in contrast to the law of large
numbers which you may have learned and
your first year stats course large log
number says the larger the sample the
better the statistics in everyday life
we don't think that way we we're ready
to generalize from any sample any size
you know oh I had I heard a friend you
know got food poisoning you know never
go to this restaurant kind of thing
right there's some truth to it but
clearly we're not taking sample size
into account
ok next example of a bias so we're still
working in doggy B&B is growing fast in
a survey of when ur dog 20 dog owners
found on SF craigslist 65 said they
would use dog B&B how would you
summarize this finding to the rest of
the company so you're working as data
scientist is your job to do these things
to some two out two run surveys to some
to conclude and then summarize you have
to write this out in the one-line
summary in your company's weekly report
how would you do that in 10 words or
less you know you can just think about
this in your head and use your fingers
if you need to ok 10 words or less
anybody want to volunteer a summary
more than half of dog owners and SF
craigslist would use dog B&B that's what
I heard good that's good summary that's
really close to what most people come up
with and when you try to summarize even
more what happens you know try to
summarize that finding in four words can
you do better than this
what's what's so hard about this we
summarize information all the time
precision I didn't hear where that came
from but that's a really good one word
answer for a very concise answer we lose
precision when we summarize information
say to retain some meaning to the
sentence we need to take out all the
qualifiers like the sample size for
example originally the information I
presented was 120 that's lost in all the
sun rays now we don't know how big the
sample is that's a loss of precision
that's the fact of life when it comes to
summarizing information there is a bias
of confidence over doubt when
summarizing information you could also
call this the headline effect so like
the headline of a newspaper story is
always going to sound more confident
than the text of the story that follows
this is unavoidable and your job as a
responsible data scientist is just to do
this honestly and point people to the
rest of the story so that they can fill
themselves in if they want to okay um
next bias on a scale of 1 to 10 where
would you put each of these words this
is an example another thing we do all
the time without thinking when somebody
asks you you know uh again how fast was
revenue growing last month we knew we
say it was growing fast really fast
super really fast we're in everyday
speech we use we use words to stand in
for numbers how do we do that it's a
mystery it's a black box right and we
think people may think we know what
we're talking about but it can be really
quite quite we could be really quite far
apart so for example
all let's let's take a poll here so if I
say that something is likely to or no
I'll take a better one if if I say that
there is yeah something is likely to
happen tell me whether you be
comfortable using that word on a scale
of one to ten okay let's let's do a
group poll here I'll just count up from
from one and then you raise your hand
when you're comfortable saying yet this
this quantity I'd say is likely okay so
one out of ten probably nobody two three
four five raise your hands so people can
see six okay a lot of people seven a lot
more people eight nine and ten do we
have any absolutists okay oh so it seems
like the bulk of people were and they
was at six six six and seven but it's a
it's if you use it you if you plotted
this out it would probably be a normal
distribution itself so we're estimating
individually what does it what does the
word likely mean and it's really cool
that we can do this we can do this
really fast but it leads to a loss of
precision again and it can be the cause
of bias so this process is called
intensity matching so back in my
facebook days I found a really amazing
really shocking example of this in the
popular press the site The Daily Beast
calm reported a finding on a survey with
the headline few facebook users click
ads in a CNBC pull a full eighty-three
percent of those surveyed said they
hardly ever or never clicked on facebook
ads did you see the intensity matching
here yeah there's a double case
happening that one the people are
to quantify their own click clicking
behavior which is not clear how you do
that and then the journalist summarizing
the results summarize the 83% into a
headline of Hugh at that point like oh
in my opinion all precision is lost and
you could easily tell the opposite story
by saying many Facebook users click ads
you could completely reverse the
headline using the same data just
because it's not clear what how people
rate these qualities any questions so
far okay
okay yeah for this next one I will ask
the audience to participate in an
experiment conveniently we have bank of
chairs here and a bank of chairs here
i'll call this group one and everybody
who's further to the left can be group 1
and over here and further the right
group two okay so group 2 I kindly asked
you to close your eyes for on 15 seconds
maybe 30 seconds starting now Group one
please read the slide answer both
questions and keep the answers to
yourself
okay Group one freeze your answer don't
change it i'm going to show groups you
now group 2 please open your eyes read
both questions think of an answer
groupon don't change your answers okay I
think that's about the same time as
Group one had group to you please freeze
your answers now we'll take a poll okay
group till you saw the second slide so a
group one you've seen both now now group
to it's your chance to see what group
one saw what's the difference there's
only one small difference right Thank
You 600 million three hundred million
how do people feel that will change the
responses of the two groups yeah one of
the groups will overestimate group one
would be expected to overestimate so
they received six hundred million and
second 30 million but notice that
they're logically the the answer the
second question does not depend on the
first question so let's see how how
about how the science holds up here so
for um let's see we'll do this in blocks
of 250 million so Group one raise your
hand if or great we'll do both groups
together to speed this process up so
raise your hand if you guess the answer
the second question how many active
users do what's up have when it was
acquired raise your hand if you your
answer was between 0 and 250 million
okay take a look around make you make an
estimate okay next block 250 to 500
okay and 500 to 750 okay I'm seeing more
slightly more on that in that block
group 1 and then 7 50 or higher okay
raise it high this is more interesting
so we got maybe four in group 1 and 1 in
group 2 ok that is evidence for the
phenomenon of anchoring right group 1
saw a higher number stated in the
question in the first question and that
influenced them to a higher answer in
the second question ok this this funnel
is really prevalent in everyday life you
when you go to the gas station you know
there's the gold silver bronze kind of
levels and you might think why would you
ever pay more pay for the gold I'm just
going to buy the silver well you know
you might be victim of anchoring then
because the marketers know this they put
always put the higher prices out there
to dry you up on the price spectrum
makes sense so this can affect your own
work you know deliberately or our are in
deliberately when you're seeing
different context you know if I'm fine
of mine anchoring my numbers of my
current start up against the numbers of
facebook I might be quite skewed okay
similarly let's try another quick
experiment this one again I'll ask group
to you to close your eyes for 20 seconds
Group 1 read the slide
answer the question keep the answer
yourself okay that's enough time freeze
the answer group 2 please open your eyes
and now you give it a shot
can everybody see back there a story if
it's a little the text a little small
yeah well the the text size should
affect both groups equally so our
results are still good okay now I'll say
this is what group one saw this is what
group to saw what's the difference the
group to receive additional information
the first two paragraphs are the same
but group to saw additional list of
steps required to complete or suggested
steps for the completion of the
experiment what do you expect the effect
of that to be it's going to increase the
estimate right even though Group one
should have been fully able to think up
the same steps required I mean that is
to say that experiments all require
these these steps in some sense okay so
let's do a quick quick poll again how
many people raise your hand if you
thought is going to take one day to run
this experiment two days to a week okay
one week to one month okay and then one
month or longer okay um it's hard it's
really hard to judge because Group one
obviously is much bigger but just
looking at the chairs sections I'd say
group too high was skewed towards longer
experiment completion time which is what
we'd expect according to the planning
fallacy this is something that you know
even without the name planning fallacy
you probably recognize from your day to
day work it's really easy to just give
an estimate off the top of your head
saying oh yeah I'll get that done in by
next week and then when you get back to
your desk you think about it you're like
holy there's no way I can get this
done by next week because you actually
have a little bit more time to think
through the steps involved the planning
fallacy is that we tend to underestimate
we tend to estimate by just thinking
like Oh what do we need to do but the
more you ask that question what do you
need to do the more things you come up
with and the more you realize that the
work involved so it's a really
pernicious pernicious bias it affects
yeah question yeah it's worth it's even
worse it affects the whole world it
affects you know probably like the Bay
Bridge you know that the city products
to notorious right everything is
everything takes more than you initially
that you're capable thinking of ya
right on yeah so the question was would
you expect additional information the
additional level of detail to also
reduce the the spread in the responses I
I would agree with that I haven't looked
into that I haven't read anything about
that yes
yep no no information about quality of
team this is probably a learned skill
also people can learn to get better at
estimating yep this is just just just
changing that one variable in the in the
information so yeah good ways to get
around this this policy is practice just
noticing your own estimates and how
close or far they're off and then also
taking the outside view that's something
that's advocated in the book Thinking
Fast and Slow don't just think about
what you can you know needs to get done
just think about what other projects
what similar projects have been done in
the past and how long did it did they
take to complete so your benchmarking
against some some independent project
okay okay one more experiment here okay
ready group to close your eyes Group one
read the two paragraphs make an estimate
okay I think that's enough time freeze
your answers group 2 please open your
eyes thank you for waiting patiently now
it's your turn to answer the question
again I apologize if the text is too
small in the back I'll read out the
question it may 2016 people viewed more
videos on snapchat than on facebook one
year before in may 2015 how likely would
you have expected this outcome to be
give an estimate on a scale of zero to
100 okay freeze your answers now I'll
show you group to what group one saw you
tell me what's different
okay so and one of them I lied right as
they both can't be true as a matter of
fact I don't even know which one I lied
in because when I look this up online
they were just about to announce that
that snapchat had overtaken facebook in
video views now the definition of what a
view is is up for is not the same but
the point still stands what's
interesting to us tonight is whether you
would have guessed this a year ago okay
let's see how people guessed so really
simple this time raise your hand if you
thought it was fifty percent or less to
your question less than fifty percent
okay okay and more than fifty percent
okay I think there was about maybe about
sixty percent of the people answered it
was fifty percent or higher overall
what's wrong with that if both groups
are seeing the logical opposites and
both were saying sixty percent I thought
that was going to be true what's going
on
anybody want to take a stab oh
after the fact you rationalize the
result that you that you know is you
know to be true right that's a really
good explanation in the literature it's
called hindsight bias so again this is
common sense but in scientists have
proven common sense to be true people do
rationalize okay we just saw it here
perhaps that people were presented to
opposite statements and unknowingly to
each other two groups and each group on
average said you know sixty percent
thought it was it was likely to happen
okay i will skip this one in the
interest of time yes yep so hindsight is
refers to like looking back in time and
when you do that and you see you know
you're talking about something to happen
now you can it's easy really easy to say
oh I knew it was going to happen all
along yeah it also called like the
rearview mirror effect or something like
that or I told you so effect it's easy
for people to be influenced and thinking
about the past about what's happening in
the president even though logically in
the past you didn't you couldn't know
anything from from the present time
confirmation bias I'm going to skip over
this one in the interest of time you can
look this up along with any of the other
ones on Wikipedia there's a list of
biases it's a fun way to kill 15 minutes
now this one is could be a lifesaver for
you guys how would you rank by chance of
death each of these forms of transport
could be a lifesaver
airbus car bicycle foot or motorcycle
rank them from safest to most lethal so
I'll let you just do this one your heads
now you can compare to the actual
results according to wikipedia surprise
they are in exactly the same order that
I originally presented them any
surprises here I was really surprised by
how relatively lethal bicycle travel and
foot travel is yeah motorcycles
motorcycles are just plain dangerous yes
in the back I don't that's a really good
question fortunately the data is just
not there on Wikipedia that's right yeah
in the whole definition of what
constitutes foot travel is up for debate
you know people walking around their
homes does that foot travel I don't know
so anyway it's kind of interesting right
and I think you did this repeatedly
you'd find the same response from people
that people would under valued like
bicycle travel or for travel or or bus
right because when we answer this
question we don't actually do the math
or ahead because we don't have we don't
know the number or at least is really
unlikely to any of you work for like
Transport Agency and you actually know
what the number of fatalities is instead
we answer much easier question in our
minds which is how like how often have
you heard of fatalities how many people
you know have been in car accidents and
that kind of thing and this is called
the dáil availability heuristic whatever
is available to memory and its
associated with availability
is right because we don't just remember
how frequently things happen we remember
things in proportion to their intensity
so the more intense something is the
more grisly accident the more likely we
are to remember it and so when then when
it comes to estimating the frequency we
overweight things by their intensity and
this is again a comment common sense
phenomenon science has proven it once
again you know it's the Phenom it's
closely related to the phenomenon of
sensationalism in the news the news
loves to show the most intense things
possible and then people come away to
think with the feeling that while this
is happening all the time because it's
always on the news but that's just not
true as a statistics show really
strongly it's interesting to think about
also at how this becomes even worse with
the advance of Technology because the
power of media is growing more and more
so the ability to you know just spread
the really intense stories is is is
increased all the time so we could we
could all becoming more biased by
availability all right okay the final
bias i want to present to you is
something that you can take home with
you to your next dinner party or maybe
you can take it to happy hour I warn you
it's really only good to pull this out
if you want to start an argument or a
heated conversation the question is
which i invite you to ask is why do
intelligent women tend to marry men that
are less intelligent than them anybody
who cares you answer the web can't
answer the guys can't answer oh it's
starting now
yeah okay inside yeah because they're
more attractive ok ok it's get somebody
yeah in the silver because I presented a
question there is a bias yeah yeah
there's a something that is true I would
argue it is true based on first
principles which I'll explain in a
moment yeah in the front
yes so that's what I was getting at
there is a trick to this question that
by presenting it as intelligent women
I'm presenting a smaller group against a
larger group of men who are just the
average male population so all else
being equal assuming nothing else you'd
expect that those women are going to
choose from the general population of
man and the general population of man on
average is less intelligent does that
make sense you know as a stronger
response than I was looking for so this
phenomenon is called regression to the
mean okay yeah comment in front yeah
right yep that's a really good point a
lot of this stuff comes down to language
and language cues different ways we have
of thinking about things and when you
present a question with the with why you
start thinking about causation and in
normal life we think about causation of
character traits you know intelligence
strength you know laziness and all these
character traits that's why we explain
why people do the things that they do we
don't think about regression to the mean
that's not it's an impersonal
statistical thing we don't think of that
as a cause normally but it can be a
cause or it can lead to these things
that look like they're caused by a by
other things and when when I when I
present a question that has really
strong political strength right because
we're in a society right now we have a
lot of talk about quality of men women a
lot of different ideas come to mind and
they crowd out all the other ideas of
just plain boring statistics if on the
other hand I presented the question why
do blondes tend to marry brunettes it's
much easier to think about notice that
because clearly there's much fewer block
there many fewer blondes in the general
population than brunettes right so it
makes sense yeah and there's no there's
no political debate about whether
blondes are equal to brunettes there
hopefully not hopefully we're past that
yeah so again that's called regression
to the mean anybody having equal any
more questions about bias easier istics
anything you come across in your own
work it's okay don't need to say
anything now I'll be around for the next
well well we enjoy each other's
companies you can come up and ask me
anything
my name is Greg Dingle Greg at par sub I
want to thank Jared for inviting me here
to speak to you all today and galvanize
for the space and Daniel Kahneman all
the other countless scientists for
solidifying this knowledge for us to use
okay thank you very much